Jerusalén amaneció esta mañana con la
sacudida de dos explosiones en dos
paradas de autobuses distintas que
remiten a los ataques con bomba de hace
más de 20 años durante la segunda
intifada el primer estallido el más
fuerte ocurrió sobre las 7 de la mañana
en el principal acceso a la parte oeste
de la ciudad y muy cerca de las
estaciones centrales de buses y trenes
una zona muy concurrida a esa hora y que
por esta detonación falleció un joven
judío de 16 años que era estudiante de
una yeshiva la segunda explosión se
produjo alrededor de media hora después
en la intersección de Ramón otro punto
neurálgico pero en el este ocupado ambos
hechos han dejado decenas de heridos la
policía israelí sospecha que ambos
ataques contaron con dispositivos dentro
de mochilas que fueron activados a
distancia y al menos una de ellas habría
sido cargada también con clavos para
maximizar los daños el aire vivo cero
policial aseguró que no se veían ataques
coordinados de este tipo en Jerusalén
desde hace muchos años de ahí que las
imágenes recordarán al levantamiento
palestino ocurrido entre los años 2000 y
2005 cuando los ataques bomba contra
autobuses se convirtieron en un sello
distintivo de momento ningún grupo
armado palestino se ha adjudicado la
autoría de estas explosiones pero tanto
jamás como la yihat islámica elogiaron
los ataques que los consideraron una
respuesta natural a la ocupación israelí
en un año que está siendo el más
mortífero en cisjordania desde 2015